okay
um additional cost applied last year to
the barges my recollection was the year
before I think was 50 but we didn't take
anything off and I'm wondering therefore
in light of what you've said
um you know for let's say to take the 10
this year and the inflationary and then
to meet with the barges and consider the
way forward if members aren't happy with
the the full three years
I don't think we actually
um did make any charges last year but
that's what I see clarification on
chairman uh Mr Leslie
yeah in these supplementary estimate
pack he's got the fees and charges um
have been detailed for the past three
years
um so it shows 21-22 and then 22 23 and
no change between those those two so
that's in there all right well you have
uh the motion on the uh the table at the
moment Council of Lagan so um I think
you have the last the right to the last
say but uh councilor siddle
uh thank you chair one thing that I
would like to check upon is what sort of
discussions officers are having with the
barge owners and you know whether we're
in in this discussion with them whether
they've got a view on these things
whether they're prepared to you know pay
a bit more in terms of things yeah my
other concern about what we reported um
on is the the uh key is a Malden
District Council asset and no matter
what we've got to maintain that so
bringing in that cost figure I think is
it is something which isn't really
necessary it would be something we'd
have to pay anyway whether the barges
are there or not but could you give us
some clarification about what
discussions have happened between us and
and the barge owners Mr Leslie yep thank
you chair but so discussions do take
place um with the barge owners
um and certainly part of the leveling up
bid as well that's um that's happened in
terms of this specific increase they've
not been engaged in any detail around
the specific increase to remove the
discounts
um my understanding not from direct
conversation I have to have to emphasize
is that the barge owners understand
um that there's a need for an
appropriate charge
um and but of course we haven't had that
detailed level of engagement on the
specific proposal around that
thank you um now the penultimate speaker
on this will be uh councilor Thompson
and then councilor Lagan to wind up
actually councilor siddle mentioned that
we'd have to pay the cost anyway but my
understanding would be that facilitation
the silt moves around because the barges
move around and if nobody used it a lot
of that wouldn't happen but what I
actually asked to speak about was
um councilor lag and saying well it's
not a discount but
I have to disagree because it it is this
discount only applies to the full rig
barges if you have a barge that isn't
full rigged you pay the full amount if
you have a different kind of vessel it's
a similar size you pay the full amount
so I don't see any way of looking at it
other than the um other than an easy
discount thank you
thank you councilor Lagann uh if you've
done that before I put the question
certainly chair um just to raise a quick
point of clarification
um uh for Council Thompson the the key
is filtered up the barges need ties low
tide where there's not a lot of water
they can only work for 90 minutes
so peace goes with facilitation in the
river it's filtered up we haven't we
haven't as a council invested enough in
the removal of facilitation that's there
okay so we had a negotiated with the
water companies as well they have a
window opportunity of two hours okay so
when you're talking about money and
value for money you know a two-hour trip
on the type before they have to let go
before they have to come up we're not
looking after the river in the way that
we need to do I think it's pretty clear
that
um and Mr Leslie said you know this is a
policy but there was an awful lot of
details applied in here so I it's for
the first time ever in my time as a
member so I want to question why because
it does it does it leads a leading uh
debate but I stand by what I've said I
think that the barge owners they do they
do want to pay they have they understand
they have to pay you know and they
should pay they should pay a fair and
actual sum of money in the respect that
what they bring to the town and the
district in revenue and income
um car parking charges restaurant fees
you know people spending money people
having holidays with us chair you know
we've even got it on our Crest except
the barges are everywhere so we're
really not measuring eggs with eggs I
understand what you're talking about
with the kiosk if there's any there's an
increase that's already set in those
contracts anyhow so I commend this to
the council I said we should support
this it brings Clarity there's a cost of
living crisis currently we're allowing
people to be able to be clear in what
they need to do set their business plans
and we can keep these things in Malden
because we are at risk of losing others
because the kitty went last year because
of the cost thank you we now have sound
members so if you speak um you can use
your microphones
um
right
um so the recommendation
um uh is for the fees and charging
policies attached as appendix a with the
exceptions of the car parking and
wolfhage now I'm assuming
uh uh I did say penultimate and final
speaker recorded vote please chairman
that's what I'm going to ask all right
okay is that seconded
right okay
um
so if I take that vote first
for the all other
all other fees and charges and the car
parking charges and then we'll come to
the vote on that is that acceptable to
members right those in favor of the
recommendation of
um appendix a plus the car parking
um charge additional document please
show
just that this this is this is all the
other fees and charges but not the
barges
um that looks like
uh uh
a positive
um vote of approval right uh a recorded
vote uh Ms Casey on
um the warfage votes
he could just repeat eat that and then
we could have the second row again
repeat that but the prevention of the
viewing public and damaging vote would
that be okay with members okay uh
councilor Lagan would you repeat your
proposal please thank you chair thank
you it
um my my motion is my proposal is that
we keep the current uh rate of fees and
charges
um and in line with what councilor
Fluker said is that we apply a an
inflationary rate uh for this year and
then for the next three years we apply
an inflationary rate of increase to that
compounded obviously year on year and
then it comes back to the council for a
full review after that
um thank you that gives me a a problem
uh Mr quelch or Mr Leslie can can we
say what's going to happen in three
years time
technically you can but whether that's
the right thing to do is another matter
but technically you can the council can
always undo
the council can always undo that yeah
okay well we'll leave it like that for
the time being then
um so if you uh chairman I have to
second it
yeah oh sorry uh councilor stamp it has
been duly seconded by councilor Stan
um all those
yeah can we just have the clear work oh
sorry
uh we just had the the word in from
councilor Lagan okay well I just thought
did you get his word in Miss Casey yes I
did
just like to know now who's going to
second according both uh um
members I will call your names in our
professional order for voting on counter
lagan's proposal on the start uh deep in
charges for the barges on the basis of
four or against
I will call your names in our special
order please stay clearly for against or
abstain yeah okay
for
four did you get that
Miss Casey yes sorry we're just having a
little diverse technical for it because
of this feel for
Belle four
time to voice abstain
sensing the mood of the chamber
um chairman for
Edwards for
or
thank you for
alcohol
four
count of the keys four
four please burner
four
at the Morgan four
all right
Stein
four
thank you Council single before
not here
four
please burner
four
cancer Swain four
four
thank you Memphis
so that's 24th proposal and two
abstentions no none against thank you
that's therefore carried and that that
deals with
um a gender item eight a little a I now
intend to bring forward agenda item 12
council tax base 23 24 contained on
pages 41-48 to be the next item
leader
um
well thank you chairman uh this is
something that we're required to set uh
the tax base for the council tax by the
31st of January 2022 the report
highlights um who we have to notify its
tax-based calculations to and it's all
done in bearing in mind the Local
Government Act 1922 as amended and
detailed in the reports set out it makes
requirements allowing you to authority
to make its arrangements for adopting
the council tax base the council tax
varies between the different bands and
it is really a technical exercise
chairman so I won't go into all the
details all should be clearly laid out
for members it's an integral part of
setting the council tax and is actually
a prerequisite for uh setting council
tax for the following year there's
appendix a there chairman and appendix b
as well which is regarding the parishes
I don't know if Mr Leslie would like to
come in chairman but I would say that we
agree the reports on it is that seconded
right that seconded
Mr Leslie do you want to make any
observations
just very briefly so like you haven't
just this is the council tax base not
the council tax set in itself it really
is a an estimate of actually the number
of properties essentially that will pay
the council tax is based on uh what's in
the system
um really so that's the actuals which
are there currently and really the only
estimates around
um growth that may happen and also our
collection rate as well the growth is
based on planning estimates and fairly
consistent with past past years as well
and the collection rate takes into
account that actually
um that there may be a bit of a downturn
going into to next year so we
conservative among that however it's
just an estimate obviously what we
actually collect will be the actuals and
and for us that is the amount that we
will receive eventually anyway so this
this is an estimate thank you okay is
that agreed members
thank you we'll now return uh to agenda
item eight
um uh b b
uh which is uh the street name and the
numbering policy uh leader
oh no sorry
chairman from uh Mrs yeah sorry uh
councilor Thompson
um
thank you chairman would you like me to
read it all out I'll try not no I think
members would know thank you um yes if
Chairman's taking this has read that
this recommendation is simply the four
four little items as laid out in the
report thank you any member Mr Speaker
is that agreed
thank you
we now go on to a gender item
um eight
B performance governance and audit
agenda item 15 Council Constitution and
scheme of Delegation General Powers
update
um councilor stamp uh thank you chairman
um can you guide me because every time I
stand up to do something to be noted I
do it wrong so do you want me to just
read it out and then you you you you
just present your report please okay you
don't need to read it out okay if you
wish no no chairman I I Rise to uh
present the performance governance and
audit committee report for the 29th of
September 2022 agenda item 15 cancel
Constitution and scheme of Delegation
General Powers update I will read the
recommendation it is recommended that
the proposed Edition be made to part
three three dash whatever that is
responsibility for functions scheme of
Delegation General Provisions as
detailed below members can see the
detail I just so proposed chairman
is that right yeah great thank you a
gender item nine to note the minutes uh
of various meetings of the council
um is there any questions under rule six
two
no no tips
gender item 10 notice of of motions
um
uh Council of fluka if you wish to uh uh
read out your motions or
what do you wish to do Council Fluker
well thank you chairman I've had
conversations with community services
and and the monitoring office about this
term and I think that we should follow
the rule and we should uh you know
propose that we refer this to the
relevant committee
um you know we've attempted to do this
on a couple of times and it's not quite
been done properly and the committee's
involved of quite rightly discounted it
so I propose chairman that it is
um I guess it goes to the overview and
scrutiny committee chairman I would say
rule um is that seconded thank you
um therefore that's referred to overview
and scrutiny uh your B motion two
councilor fluka thanks chairman um look
you know I'm trying to do this in the
spirit of things and and I I think it's
absolutely important bearing in mind
that many of the non-statitary items
that we deal with fiscally come through
the corporate plan and whilst I
understand officers concern that there
may well be a change of administration
and indeed a feeling about this Council
in May
um I still think it's an absolutely
important chairman that we don't leave
them without a funded corporate plan
they can if we agree if we agree the
budget and the corporate plan if they
want to change it they can but I don't
think we'll be able to I don't think
it'd be right to leave them a legacy of
not having a corporate plan
um John I'm sure officers have thought
of this and and I think it came through
and quit me if I'm wrong
the performance governance and audit
working group this was said and I I was
quite surprised because it's not
normally be the procedure to follow so
Tim and I I think in the spirit of the
motion I'm more than happy to have it
refer to that committee for
consideration and perhaps I'll meet with
the 151 officer to discuss
um what the impact of not doing this
would be thank you right um therefore
that's referred to uh strategy and and
resources thank you thank you Council uh
sorry yes
thank you counselor Hill
um a gender item 11 questions in
accordance with a procedural rule six
three which notice has been given there
is none we have done the gender item 12
agenda item 13 Chelmsford city council
local plan review issues options and
consultation response Pages
49-56 uh leader
um
sorry chairman just take my mask off for
this I don't know I can't read my screen
so I've taken some notes yes chairman
this is really
um
a member wanting to or rather the
council needing to hopefully ratify
holding response this was submitted to
Chelmsford city council
um German and there should be um the
appendix with the report we were invited
back in August to comment as a statutory
consultee regarding Chelmsford local
plan review issues and options
consultation and there's been various
meetings I was invited to a duty
copyright meeting
with the chairman of strategy and
resources and some officers
um and since that time officers have
been concentrating across the On the
Border issues and strategic matters
their current um local plan was adopted
relatively recently
um in May 2020 but they're now obviously
going through the review process and
wanting to update that plan and the plan
period up till 2041. I won't go on on
chairman really we're seeking um
ratification of this but I'm sure an
officer would like to come in and
explain
we didn't answer all the questions what
officers did were they looked at the
pertinent questions regarding our
Authority again members met and went
through that and that's the response
here tonight and I believe it's been off
by by councilor white so and I believe
they've got it this we're seeking
ratification of and I'm sure
um the the relevant auspicer would like
to come in and explain it in more detail
than I can thank you but I I do um I um
propose that recommendation chairman is
that secondly
okay uh with shortland
well she usually does
and the importance of strategic
cross-boundary issues in the response so
there are things like education
things that cross our borders there's
not enough information at this time for
us to make any comment to support or
oppose any particular spatial approach
in the consultation
so we're asking for uh the holding
response that we've submitted to
Chelmsford city council
um Can it can a document be approved
thank you members councilor stamp
thank you chairman
um could I actually just say um that's
because obviously many of us haven't
been um party to the conversations that
God has gone on with Chelmsford city
council officers
um could I actually ask that we robustly
do Challenge and don't roll over for any
more development that is going to most
probably come to South Woodham Ferris
I'm sure the people who live at that
side of the district is absolutely fine
but the rest of us who live this side of
the district has noticed a huge amount
of traffic increasing traffic and I know
that when the last local plan I think
that's fluca if he chooses may be able
to help me out on this one
um when when they're due to cooperate
they didn't want to cooperate with us I
think that was right Council Channel as
well when it was the last RDP yeah so so
I would actually ask because I do
actually read if you notice on 3.6
members and officers it says to ensure
opportunities are capitalized on the
impacts and adequately mitigated where
where they cannot be avoided now I know
that's speak in planning terms but in
actually layman's terms of people
actually live there I would hope that we
can robustly challenge the development
because I think one of the areas in our
old in our own ldp that was going to be
considered for a development site was
actually next to one of their sites and
I my understanding is that they robustly
wanted us not to actually put that
forward so I actually would hope and I'm
sure that the officers will say they
will do this but I'd like it noted that
I have stood up chairman and I do want
it robustly challenged that we are not
going to be put upon that um roundabout
at Southwood and Ferris you've always
got a poor old car going up on Lori's
backside because nobody stepped can seem
to navigate it properly and it has a
massive impact to everybody who lives in
Burnham the Dengue latchingdon Etc
chairman so I'd like that noted thank
you I'm sure that will be and I agree
with every word you've said and I'm
impartial
um any other member
right
um agreed that uh with the uh with the
advisory from councilor stamp yeah I
agreed all right agreed
um a gender item 14 delegation of power
to get dispensation to code of conduct
interests and we all know what this is
all about on 57-58
um I'll go to the leader but I'm sure
this is a Mr quilts issue leader uh
thank you very much chairman uh really
uh this is um Mr crochet monitoring
officer really I think trying to make
the system more efficient and effective
here because if someone uh you know
comes to the monitoring officer to
wanting to make dispensation there's not
always time to go to and set up a joint
standards committee which is the body at
the moment which agrees to that so
what's being sought here and I'm doing
it from memory I hope I'm right I think
Mr quilt is seeking that he'll be given
to him and within consultation with the
independent person and I think that's
the number of it but please Mr quilch
come in but I would propose the
recommendation chairman as on the order
paper
Mr Cross do you wish to say anything uh
no chairman I think again the leader has
done a wonderful job in summarizing okay
it makes perfect sense but can you it's
an example of what would need you know
super Speedy
um ratification or just dispensation
based on Mr Bill sorry yes just just yes
um in fact this report came about
because a member in one of the area
planning committees that there were some
members
um that felt that they had an interest a
number of members in an area planning
committee in relation to a development
and
there would have been huge that that
would have in fact meant that the
business couldn't have been transacted
because there were so many members in
the area planning committee that could
have been affected and had an interest
under the new code of conduct so uh that
prompted me to write that this report so
there's a very good example and I think
particularly because the new code of
conduct is more rigorous
and
if you have a an other registerable
interest
now you need to actually and it's and
it's direct you need to actually leave
the debating chamber whereas under the
old code it was less rigorous so I think
there's going to be many more times
where lots of members have the same
interest and so business might not be
transacted
yeah thank you chairman I mean look this
this came about as a result of a
planning application that went to
Southeast area planning committee and
every member had an interest by virtue
of the fact that property was owned by
this Council and at that particular
stage we had absolutely nothing in place
to allow us to conduct that that
business and it was only because that
meeting was canceled
um that we we've actually picked up on
this but you know I still do I still do
have problems about dispensations
particularly so where you've got
jawheaded members who who sit on both
this District Council and Parish
councils and uh and I've I fear that I'm
going to engage with the mansion and
officer over this in relation to an item
that's being
um
considered at the southeast area
planning committee on Wednesday because
I don't think that the code of conduct
is there to disenfranchise members who
are dual-headed I don't see that and I
think that bearing in mind there is no
beneficial game for members serving on
councils I think that
some of this needs to be thought through
and I'm not sure if the local government
association's interpretation on this is
wholly correct but I do look forward to
my exchanges with the monitoring officer
over the next few days at least up until
7 30 p.m on Wednesday thank you
um councilor Thompson thank you Jim it's
just a question for clarity please
review for Mr quilt I mean this isn't
about dispensations for in on individual
matters this is in fact so whichever
committee is sitting it isn't that core
we're talking about when numbers of
members wouldn't be able to vote without
this
not for one person with one issue
yeah I guess cancel yes sorry I'm sorry
I saw this completely differently
because my understanding was based on
the Preamble when this report was
presented was that the whole idea of
this was not to bug The Joint standards
committee down by people asking for
dispensation so it could be an
individual dispensation or it could be a
whole dispensation I mean if I did I
misunderstand the Preamble or is does
this only apply to where everybody is
requiring a dispensation
um
dispensations can be applied for by
individual members where there is only
one member as well as where there are
many members like the very good example
that councilor Fluker gave
um
and so there is no restriction
normally a dispensation would only be
given where business couldn't be
transacted
um that that's a force that's a very
good reason for giving dispensation
there's less reason for giving
dispensations in the ordinary course of
events where there isn't one individual
that has a problem otherwise you could
be giving dispensations all the time and
the code of conduct would never work and
um members would never have to leave the
debating chamber as is intended by the
code of conduct
thank you thank you uh members agree
this agree thank you uh then we come uh
we've got 10 minutes before I intend to
adjourn or close the meeting uh leaders
questions questions to the leader
Council Flocka
um
leader since May 22.
can you give three examples where in
your capacity is leaders you you brought
forward policies to the Council on
behalf of the conservative
Administration
leader
[Applause]
oh sorry I've got my glasses on
um chairman what I would refer to
actually is my Leader's statement made
in June where I set out the program for
this Municipal year and indeed that
document doesn't say what say what the
intentions are for this Authority and
there will be things coming forward as
you'll be aware councilor fluka because
your question and I would refer you to
that statement what our intentions are
we have started the review of the
corporate plan which will expire
in 2023 there'll be an event strategy
should be coming forward
and also the other elements of the
leader speech in there and um
that is what I would say I have done in
the leader speech which will be coming
to fruition and finishing at the end of
2023 thank you councilor
councilman Maids
we had three questions now
everybody's got to have a share
Council Mays thank you Mr chairman um
yes leader
um the cemetery team in this Council
does an awesome job
uh it has come to my attention that they
um
also bring in a significant level of
income however there is no budgets
allocated to the statutory work that
they have to do
will this important function of the
council be properly funded and the
department given a suitable budget going
forward
thank you
leader
um well there's certainly fees and
charges relating to cemeteries and I'm
sorry I thought we had an officer here
that was involved in the cemeteries I've
certainly engaged with them and
certainly
um
oh sorry um are you interrupting okay
I'll sit down okay thank you no I was
just going to come back um Madam leader
and just say you can't come back
and say this there there is not a budget
okay
um
well if you're if you're unsure I was
going to say what I would be doing is I
will be actually uh checking this out
and I will give you a full
um response in writing because I will
look into all that
because I know that um uh councilor
stamp is Keen to gain
um
I've just listened and made a few notes
about what the leader just said and yeah
of course I know all about the lead of
speech but there was absolutely no
mention about budget
chairman this the budget deficit this
year is now reported to be three
quarters of a million pounds so that's
the equivalent of using 15 000 pounds a
week a taxpayers money
but the leaders confirmed just confirmed
she has got any policies with regards to
the budget will be given her the
opportunity and she's referred back to
her statement
so
I can't help saying this leader but
under your leadership this council is
underperforming and when warned about
the impending financial disaster you
refuse to support the calling the
northern budget
we can't continue like this the
council's budget is imploded on your
watch
and there are no policies to stem the
flow of money out of this Council
will you now act in the best interests
of our residents and stand down to allow
somebody more financially astute to lead
the council out of this financial
predicament
and if not leader why not
uh thank you chairman I cannot well I
will answer that the budget actually
councilor fluka was in the previous
municipatory I delivered the budget in
February and the statement I was
referring to was from the subsequent
Municipal Year from May onwards so and I
did make a budget speech and it also was
to cover obviously this Municipal year
you're talking about the budget and the
things that are happening what I would
say to you on this the council has gone
through its budget cycle which provides
updates on the financial position and
brought forward savings options we have
a clearer picture of the financial
challenges we Face through this as well
this is global issues and we like all
other authorities cannot shy away from
the tough decisions we need to make
which is why it is important they are
done in a sensible and strategic way to
avoid unnecessary impact to our
community
what I would also say uh given the
financial pictures have changed for all
local authorities across the year and an
Autumn budget would not necessarily have
been able to secede and address some of
the current changes
and as you know you sit on the working
group Council of Luca which which
Council put you on my recommendation and
you're also strategy resources we are
all working together on that cross-party
working group to look at the future
going forward you're as well as well as
I am of what has been said in those
meetings and what I would say is the
council is using its reserves which is
built up for situations such as we have
because I think that's what you're
referring to the cost of living crisis
and our reserves being utilized with
taxpayers money I appreciate to mean
service levels at a time of great need
for residents and businesses to assist
with their prosperity and sustainability
this is a challenging time Mr Fluker the
Council of Luca beg your pardon this is
a challenging time for everyone and we
will do all we can to support them
Council who can I really do believe that
this is what this Council will do
officers and members are working
together to look at Financial plans
moving forward into 20 23 24 as part of
the regular process and Council and on
the 15th of December we'll be receiving
Financial options with recommendations
from strategy and resources committee
what I would also like to say is at the
recent treasury Management training
session it was said reserves are there
for when times get difficult and crisis
the 151 officer has explained recently
at the finance working group that the
budget Gap due to a number of economic
factors has grown and the budget survey
though which we've heard from our
residents is indicating to this
Authority where the priority should be
and one of which is the cost of living
and support for our residents your right
Council of Luca regarding the impact of
various things on the budget or I'm
going to tell you now that's covid and
of course the cost of living crisis and
I think it's very important we bear that
in mind but I would also like to
highlight that the LGA is also lobbying
government very intensively and has
written directly on behalf of all member
authorities to the chancellor as well
highlighting the financial situation of
local government and that if severe
cutbacks were made including for the
most vulnerable in our society this
would not only do damage to our
communities but massively undermine
government Ambitions about economic
growth and help residents through the
most at this through this cost of living
crisis government is being urged to
urgently provide Financial
sustainability and certainty for
councils so they can keep communities
running and deliver for residents six
leaders and chief executors have also
had discussions because there's
authorities all in the same position so
I'm highlighting what's going on and as
I said back in my leader statement in
June I referred to the issues that were
coming up for this Council not of my
doing I would say Council of hookah this
is about what's happening in England
what's happening in Essex what's
happening across the globe as the
government has said in fact the Prime
Minister has Mr Rishi sooner the right
honorable MP
uh well the Essex authorities rule in
the same boat regarding Finance finances
and as I said in my leader speech uh
back in uh June uh that Municipal year
what we hope to achieve the remainder of
it I referred the continuing
opportunities with all the local
authorities to arrive where Services
could perhaps be shared to assist I did
bring that forward within that document
and I didn't highlight that but we must
continue to prioritize our resources
work in Partnership where possible and
invest our time and effort in areas that
fulfill core Services we also need to
help support our residents and
communities to improve quality of life
and I know that's a long explanation
move on right quickly counselor
um stamp
thank you chairman I feel a bit mean now
leader what I'm going to say and ask
because um but I am going to ask it
um I did ask you quite some time ago if
you would consider all chairman and vice
chairmans of all the Committees actually
having a meeting so we could actually
look at taking the council forward I
think on the basis of what council for
Lucas just actually said I think it'd be
a very good idea I know that you had
some reservations about actually uh
um taking that a step further but I
think it's actually very important now
the second thing I'm going to say in
defense of you Lisa and regarding what
council fluke has said it just shows
exactly that transformation wasn't
hasn't fulfilled and delivered the
savings that it was supposed to deliver
and I don't think anybody can just blame
you sitting in that seat about the
economic downturn and what every council
at all levels are going to experience at
the moment not to negate what cancer
Lucas then has got every right to say it
but I don't think it's fair just to
Target you leader thank you oh thank you
uh leader um do you wish to answer the
first bit about a meeting of all um yes
we did have a conversation and actually
I think I actually said to cancel the
stamp at that time yes I had thought
about it and I must admit being with
every other opportunity or an
opportunity everything else going on I
suppose that slipped my mind but yes and
in fact you should have had an invite to
something uh recently a meeting I do
hope we spoke about it I think you said
you questioned whether policy planning
was running because the late bite I
think that might tell you or inform you
where I'm meeting perhaps some of that
first part of your question thank you
I'm I'm sorry I'm now going to close the
meeting uh counselor
uh uh fluke I I I can I will adjourn the
meeting then so after the next meeting
we can come back to the third question
and the rest of the agenda
um meeting uh is now adjourned
[Music]